can we just talk about emily for a
second
emily didn't do anything i think emily's
mom made a very bad mistake taking her
away from this
it's never fun to be in the bottom
but you got outperformed
emily's mom did not like the feedback i
gave her after the dance we're not used
to being
at the bottom
at all
so she took her kid in the middle of the
night i went back to florida i was
blindsided
i don't know
where your head is but like i would do
anything get you back her dad was upset
because she was in the bottom five i
told him i said listen your kid is the
favorite
listen i've been in this position i was
a 10 year old on a reality tv show i was
in her exact situation it's hard
i think caroline taking emily was the
worst thing that she could have done i
think
what that taught emily
is
that when things get tough you quit
i am devastated right now
i don't want her to be a distraction
like i want these kids to stay focused
you have such good kids right now it's
not worth it emily's is not the right
one there's nine kids i guess now that
want to be here
i need a singing leader interesting
cause you had one
she ditched yeah i need someone that's
like a sure thing
that gets it that's gonna sing it and
sell it
[Music]